the u.s. faces a serious shortage of
primary care doctors the very doctors
who provide critical services for poor
and elderly patients by 2030 there will
be about 50,000 fewer primary care
physicians than we'll need and those
physicians increasingly practice far
from rural areas where people who lack
access to care the most and to live but
a new paper from AEI provides a solution
Peter brewer house shows that nurse
practitioners can do much of what
primary care doctors do and in a
fraction of the cost the workforce of
nurse practitioners is growing too
especially in underserved areas and
nurse practitioners are more likely to
treat low-income patients and people
with disabilities so what's stopping
nurse practitioners from stepping up 28
states restrict their scope of practice
out of a concern for quality of care
well good news
Faraz shows that such concerns are
unfounded states should let nurse
practitioners do their job disadvantaged
Americans need their help and the rest
of us need a health care system that is
affordable what do you think about Peter
browses research let us know in your
comments also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI